i'm like shaking for her my soul kills
dies for her
no she's not awake and what's so crazy
is
he wrote a whole declaration let me read
this to you
hold on i'm literally shaking
kylie jenner's not shying away from
showing how she really feels about
tristan thompson after learning about
his paternity scandal i love that
the episodes are more a little bit
documentary style and i think that you
have a real insight into what the girls
are doing not only you know what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes on
who lose the kardashians chloe's family
finds out about tristan who she briefly
reconciled with fathering a child with
someone else it all went down on
december 3rd when kim got an alert to an
article online that published court docs
it's his whole thing saying i'm tristan
thompson met this girl in houston i
slept with her on my 30th birthday so i
sent it to him and i said does chloe
know about this chloe doesn't even know
yeah tristan admits in the docs to
having a one-night stand with fitness
model marylee nichols on the night of
his 30th birthday and kylie she says
what's really on her mind after hearing
all the details
no i know i'm filming right now but
it's this is always what happens with us
because i'm always filming when it
happens then as kim reads more of the
document courtney joins the call and
gives her opinion about it too
i mean she
it's just insane in general right well
no the whole thing is this is just a
never-ending like
but it's never ending betrayal is what
it is chloe's reaction to the news we'll
have to stay tuned until next week to
watch it all unfold but we know from the
teaser she's obviously going through it
i wanted to trust him i'm so anxious
what chloe how do you when did you faint
[Music]
you know
and gotta give coco props she's always
been super transparent with fans i am an
open book and i like to be that way but
it can change at any time but when e.t
caught up with the fam ahead of the
show's premiere chloe opened up about
her limits i think for every sister we
have different boundary levels and we
all try to respect that and but i think
and probably moving forward we might all
have and like your boundaries are
allowed to change and mine will probably
change later but
i'm also i think a lot of us are you
know what is in the media is sort of
things that we feel we need to film
because it's
in a way unfair to the viewers if they
don't get to see that so i think moving
forward things might change with me but
who knows
[Music]
you